مناسب لكبير الحجم
أولا
من فضلك ، من فضلك 20،000. عاجل
هناك شخص معادل
ضرب زلزال محافظة إيشيبا
الرجاء إسقاط الأشياء من مكان مرتفع
ربما قبل كل شيء ، حاول أن تكون آمنًا
إرضاء طوكيو كاناغاوا سايتاما شيبا إيباراكي جونما توتشيغي
هناك زلزال طارئ يجري في المنطقة التي تنظر إليها
ضرب زلزال في محافظة تشيبا.
على الرغم من أن الإجراءات قد تراجعت تدريجيا
لا تضعه على قدميك بعد
ضرب هزة كبيرة جدا
يصدر هذا الاستوديو أيضًا ضوضاء عالية
كانت الأمور تهتز من مكان مرتفع
قد تسقط أولا وقبل كل شيء ، الجميع
يرجى محاولة إبقاء سلامتك مطفأة فجأة
هناك خطر الإصابة إذا دخلت
الرجاء التصرف بحذر
خاصة أنه يبلغ من العمر 8 سنوات ، يقفز فجأة إلى الطاولة
ويمكن أن تكون خطيرة جدا
معلومات مثل الاهتزاز
حسنًا ، الآن وكالة الأرصاد الجوية اليابانية
أنا أحسب ، سأخبرك بمجرد أن أفهم
لكى يفعل
الآن في وقت طوكيو Roppongi Hills Color Current image
فعلا
إنه فيديو مباشر. هل هو فيديو مباشر؟
محاضر لإخماد الارسال حسنًا ، لقد هدأ الاهتزاز قليلاً الآن
على الرغم من أنه أصبح
إنه يهتز ، يبدو أنه لا يزال يبيع قليلاً
لكى يفعل
منذ فترة
ضرب زلزال محافظة تشيبا وتسبب في هزة كبيرة
معلومات عن شدة الزلازل التي تضرب بشكل رئيسي منطقة كانتو
سأخبرك في أقرب وقت
إنه زلزال إن Shingo Tomatsuridai فوق 5 Saitama
الجزء الجنوبي من المحافظة ، قوي 5 ضعيف ، 23 جناحًا ، طوكيو ، محافظة كاناغاوا الشرقية
محافظة سايتاما الشمالية محافظة غرب تشيبا الشمالية الغربية
لقد لاحظت هزة قوية في حوالي الساعة 10:41 في وقت سابق.
إذا كان مركز الزلزال هو أفضل تسونامي في قاع البحر
لا يزال حول مركز الزلزال
لا يوجد أستاذ واضح ،
و
أهههههههه